Tō Tātou Takiwā, Tō Tātou Wāheke 2048.
Te Rautaki Whanake Takiwā
The Waimakariri District is a great place
to live, work, visit and play.
And this has not gone unnoticed, our population
and business sectors have been growing rapidly.
About 57,000 people currently call the Waimakariri
District their home
and by 2048 our population may be close to 100,000 people.
We are now planning on how best to manage
that growth over the next 30 years.
Where will people live, work and play?
Do we have enough land for business and housing
and what should happen in our rural areas?
How will our infrastructure meet this increased
demand
and how should we safeguard our natural environment?
The District Development Strategy will guide
long term growth in our district and provide
the direction for more detailed Council documents
such as the upcoming District Plan review.
It covers seven main themes, which we’ll
be taking a closer look at in later videos:
We’d like your feedback on this draft strategy
before it’s finalised later this year.
You can view the document at any Council Service
Centre or visit waimakariri.govt.nz/districtdevelopment